[Music]
fear on the streets of Kiev earlier this
week is once again the Ukrainian Capital
comes under attack by so-called suicide
drones
officially both Russia and Iran say
Iranian drones are not being used in the
aerial bombing campaign
but photographic evidence seems to
contradict that these pictures experts
say show a Shaheed 136 a drone only
manufactured by Iran that is lethal but
also relatively cheap costing about
twenty thousand dollars a piece
the UK U.S and France believe the sale
of Iranian drones and their use in
Ukraine is a breach of resolution 2231
which endorsed the 2015 Iran nuclear
deal we want to clarify the situation on
this use of Iranian drones in Ukraine
and it seems to be crystal clear that
it's a violation of resolution 2231
endorsing the gcpoa the jcpoa or Iran
nuclear deal between Iran and the
so-called P5 plus one the U.S UK France
Germany Russia and China includes a
provision for something called Snapback
if Iran is not complying any other
participating Nation can force all the
previous U.N sanctions to snap back into
place but one expert says that's a
measure Western Nations will be
reluctant to take now the risk of
snapping back sanctions over an issue
that is not directly related to Iran's
nuclear program is that Iran has
threatened that it would not only
withdraw from the nuclear deal it would
also withdraw from the nonproliferation
treaty and of course the last country
that did that was North Korea in 2003
and we know how that story ended Ukraine
has recovered drones that have been shot
down and has written to the UN urging
that inspection teams are now sent to
examine them but Russia's Deputy
Ambassador strongly objected to that
idea we hope that the Secretariat and
the Secretary General himself will not
again violate the decisions of the U.N
security Council and will not go beyond
their technical mandate and will abstain
from engaging in any illegitimate
investigation
otherwise we will have to reassess our
collaboration with them he wouldn't
elaborate on that somewhat ominous
warning and didn't completely rule out a
link with the deal to export Ukrainian
grain which was agreed last summer and
has to be extended within the next month
James Bay's Al Jazeera of the United
Nations